health experts continue to deal with
covid19 they're encouraging everyone to
get out and get that flu shot
bianca holman shares how immunized
nevada partnered with the asian
community development council
to reach more people in the valley today
the flu vaccine is given to millions of
americans each year
and this year immunized nevada is
hosting various clinics and
neighborhoods like chinatown
to ensure that the vaccine is accessible
to everyone the flu is a very contagious
respiratory disease that could lead to
hospitalization or even death cars lined
up to receive not only the flu vaccine
but also groceries for the family and
halloween treats for the kids
partnering organizations say this type
of event is necessary to protect
everyone
mostly the asian community
is shy about asking for help so here we
are
providing assistance for them in this
type of pandemic
it's great news because it means that we
truly increase the awareness
to the community that it's important to
get the flu shot and
also means that they care about
themselves and they care about other
people in the community the flu vaccine
reduces the need to see the doctor
freeing up health care resources for
cobin 19 patients
immunized nevada has two clinics later
this week reporting in chinatown bianca
holman 8 news now